Michael Gove made a speech this week
where he said Britain had the warmest
attitude to migration he was ridiculed
laughed at shouted down the implication
being that this country is inherently
racist and treats migrants like this
we don't one of the least racist
countries in any mature Western
democracy and were certainly the least
racist in Europe but anyone who dares to
say that its accused of sticking up for
the racist or being racist themselves
and then there was that that wedding yes
it was joyous and uplifting and Megan
looked incredible but I am sick of
commentators peddling the notion the
black Brits have been waiting for a
dark-skinned Duchess to make them feel
British and feel better about themselves
and white Brits needed to see a
mixed-race woman marrying Harry to
realise that black people are acceptable
it's patronizing and it's insulting yes
in a population of 65 million people
there will be racist but this nation is
not racist and the liberally defames and
disrespects the people of this country
by conflating those who simply want to
control the numbers coming here with the
miniscule numbers who do hate immigrants
[Music]
Carol I don't I don't disagree with all
you've said but and I'm gonna leave I
think Megan Markov bringing of mixed
race blessings onto our country first
for someone else because what I want to
what I want to talk about is the fact
that it wasn't what he said but the fact
that was Michael Gove who said it and
Michael Gove fronted the vote leave
campaign which didn't have a dog whistle
when it came to anti-immigrant sentiment
it was a loud clarion call there were
posters threatening the arrival of 76
million Turks into your village and I'm
yeah they terrified me and I'm part
Turkish but you know the fact is is that
he stoked fear of immigration throughout
the campaign and now to say come in the
water's lovely everybody we are woman
but not a hostile and cold environment
is frankly very rich because since the
country voted to leave as he suggested
in those posters there's been a spike in
hate crime but worse our own Home
Secretary who is a
Pakistani origin yesterday gave a speech
in which he detailed the anti-immigrant
abuse that his brother gets on the
street
people shouting [ __ ] at him and this has
happened since he's you know in the in
the recent time but there's also been a
poll which actually proves that that
brexit so times here mobile racism
because since breaks has been a success
immigration high leaking a lot has
working very of immigration has fallen
to its lowest level since the financial
crash where people think for exits dealt
with immigration we don't have to worry
about it anymore we can actually start
thinking about all the good things that
the immigrants okay so one thing you
said that that the leave campaigns don't
fear I think that's rich coming from a
remainder the remain calm fake campaigns
still fear it remain they don't feel
immigration let's go let's talk about
this what you call about the spike in
hate crime in 2016-17 there were
fourteen and a half thousand
prosecutions for hate crimes that is
seven percent down on the previous year
yes
they're one of the reasons that the
figures appear to have increased and not
actually have increased is because or
not necessarily increased it's because
the police have found a new way to
record crimes so it might look like
there are more but there aren't
necessary more now this has come out of
lots of the organizations and lots of
pills so you can't just say this be the
you know I think the British people get
really fed up
I've been slated as racist they're
bombarded every day by allegations of
racism this is one of the most welcoming
countries in the world do you look at
you know the fraks look at France anew
they say oh the Republic doesn't see
color the Republic doesn't see where
they're coming from in this country
thank God we do we are obsessive about
and so obsessive we we take people who
come here we educate them we give them
homes we give them welfare we look after
the name that's why everyone wants to
come to this Cody my my husband is a
migrant he came here from Bosnia and but
long before the war and he says that
this is the least racist country has
ever been to his life his friends who
during the war were sent to countries
like Germany like France like Italy they
all encountered vicious nasty race this
country is not a racist and only my
people must be getting really sick of
being accused of it okay so I
there's a I grew up in the early
nineties as you know Carol being chased
by neo-nazis skinheads who were
attacking me with hammers and knives and
screwdrivers and I was the Dwayne Brooks
off the Stephen Lawrence analogy there
because I had to watch many of my
friends stabbed because of the color of
their skin and I was not stabbed just
like Dwayne Brooks but many of my
friends were put hammers put to the
heads and machetes put to their bodies
because of the color of their skin I was
15 years old I refer to that as a battle
days of racism yeah I do think that
there are two things you've said that
are correct Britain despite that
experience I had is more welcoming than
most continental European countries that
must be acknowledged and the second is
that they were the bad old days of
racism certain progress has been made
we now have a British Pakistani Mayor of
London I could never have dreamed yes at
the same time as that happening that
we'd have a British Pakistani Home
Secretary I think it's important that we
acknowledge and give credit where credit
is due otherwise when we do raise
serious concerns about racism that is
rearing its ugly head across Europe that
those concerns aren't taken seriously if
we keep crying wolf so I try very hard
to give credit where credit is due
even though of course they're both from
different ends of the political spectrum
but its diversity in inaction right
there with sergeant Valens Sadiq Khan
but just I think this week Osman Ali
bhai Brown was talking about the royal
marriage and you know she has her views
but she's got the right to those smaller
Republican views and Nadine Doris yeah
it'd be nice not what she didn't say she
said more than that you should be
grateful she said she actually implied
that Yasmin should be grateful and stop
complaining because this country's given
her everything and I just find that I
find that this approach to to basically
telling people that are of color who
have some criticisms that they are
political criticisms whether at the
monarchy on the system why I'm saying we
have to be vigilant is because it can
wear it again I wouldn't derail Carole's
argument because of what Nadine Doris
says in one tweet the broad trust or the
central point of grammar is that this
country is very welcoming
if we look at the last names that's
three of the panel so around it there's
a clear that's probably is there's no
dispute yeah all I'm saying is we need
to be vigilant but it doesn't rear its
head again because you'll for saying
that people were saying you know hey
he's good he's not saying I agree with
the content of his speech like Rachel I
agree with what was said in terms of the
content of identity politics but I just
think it's unfortunate that he was the
guy that said it because of the brexit
campaign I agree with Rachel there I
found it quite ironic Carol that you're
saying Britain there's no longer racist
at the same time as talking about our
dark skinned Dutch s I think you know
what am I supposed I just Duchess I just
found that I say really uncomfortable
what should I say
why should I say I just don't know why
you referred to have that way because
the whole of the debate around the
wedding was about the color of her skin
and the fact that she's very possible
giant even though I'm not usually a big
Monica I've always respected the fact
that people feel emotion about the world
the royal family because I understand
identity and I think for many people
they represent cultural continuity which
is part of their sense of belonging and
I respect that because in my life I've
searched a lot for a sense of identity
and I didn't personally find it in the
royal family partly because I think they
perpetuated this idea that there's
something inherently White's about
British identities on the question about
racism I think we're misunderstanding
what racism is you've taken racism as a
thing that people do you know a
prejudice that they get accused of to me
that's not what racism in statistics but
you said [ __ ] people are sick of
being accused of being raped because
they're not when I talk about racism I'm
not accusing individual people and there
are racist people as you've agreed we
all know there's magic got being up by
them growing up well what's his friends
get beaten up by them my interest isn't
really in them my interest is in how is
the society we structurally discriminate
and treat unfairly people based on their
race and that is what report oft report
whether commissioned by David Cameron to
resume attend I each army the UN envoy
who came here and and special wrapped
around the fouls that incorrectly the
rationale racism has got right let's
talk about that special that special
reporter who came across to actually do
reporting she was here for all of eleven
days she spoke exclusively to pressure
groups
then she went home again after 11 days
she decided that this country had
normalized racism I'm sorry that's just
no way to rush I want to just get the
victim in the thick of being accused of
being racist please I was not you know
there's another area where just want to
give credit where credit is due I was so
furious when that wind rush of a scandal
erupted but actually what I found Hart
in and what I found was the actually
unified reaction from across the
political lines of disgust and
abhorrence at what had happened and so I
think there is some solace to be found
in the way in which this country
uniformly whether conservative labor or
anything else in between
sounds like gender doesn't it reacted in
response to that wind rose we're out of
us I mean the fact that could happen
though is a terrible thing and so that
that's why I keep saying we must
remember there is related to Carol's
topic that's why was the immigration has
been weaponized against people of color
it's not a coincidence there was a black
and brown people which we happened